servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem drittel auf wie läuft ein klein
wenig denn ich war die letzten tage
immer konsequent jeden tag in der uni
bis nachts um zwölf und habe auch einige
frage zu beantworten mir da viel viel
viel und fleißig fragen gestellt unter
dem hashtag essentiell
die habe ich mir auf meinen die
rausgesucht wir suchen jetzt gerade
nochmal einen coolen spot wo wir den
video drehen können ich bin grad auch im
auto unterwegs und dann sehen wir uns
gleich wieder da sind wir leute wir
haben uns jetzt hier diesen spot
rausgesucht
hier werden ein bisschen die beine
vertreten und ich will wissen auf eure
fragen an worden und wir legen los wie
gesagt hashtag essentiell alles klar
zack zack ist fragt wie sieht es mit
einem server aus hab schon bock auf
sowas wie legend webserver ist ein thema
ich habe den jahr gesponsert bekommen
aber die frage jetzt gerade ist was
machen wir damit weil ich sie im stream
bisschen doof finde auf dem server zu
spielen erstens weil die meisten leute
nicht interessiert
und die leute die es interessiert die
kaufen sich dann vielleicht 36 autos
die leute katies interessiert kaufen
sich dann vielleicht nur auf diesem
server spielen zu können
der subskription oder schreiben bei mir
und das will ich halt auch nicht ich
will auch nicht rüberkommen wie jemand
der den server einrichten damit
möglichst viele leute sagen weil dafür
war es eigentlich geht als dankeschön
gedacht
deswegen habe ich es erst mal pausiert
das ding ja das ist es
die session der quax at großer tv ist
das hashtag essentiell
willich essentiell
also wenn er s ens schreit geld und da
muss ich ganz klar sagen mein lieber
mann essenziell wenn du essentiell klar
dumme frage eigentlich vom wachstum was
ganz ehrlich wenn ich sowas nochmal sehr
an die dos santos
jogis gerät regina who fragt wie lange
denkst du wirst noch weiterführen gut
crashen action momentan sich einig keine
kann nun keine deadline oder keine frist
zu der ich sagen könnte sie mit youtube
auffallen will es ist ein fortschritt
begriffen es entwickelt sich immer
weiter
und deswegen hat man eigentlich nie so
wirklich bedürfnisse aufteilen also ich
würde das am liebsten ja so lange machen
wie ich kann so lange wie möglich
ehrlich gesagt und das darauf dass dafür
zu sorgen dass es immer weiter wächst
aber das geht jetzt schon voll die
schulte diese kamera zu halten ich
unterschätze das immer obwohl ich nicht
trainiert bin aber trotzdem shake rag
hörnchen spd fragt hersteller essentiell
hast du noch konkrete ziele / wünsche
für youtube oder ist es gut wie es ist
ich habe mir persönlich das 200.000
autos gesetz ganz klar so als richtwert
auf dem man hinarbeiten kann dass er
meinen traum irgendwann diesen silbernen
play button dazu haben es vielleicht ist
das bisschen affig wahrscheinlich ist es
schon affig aber das finde ich einfach
cool so als ziele was man hinarbeiten
100.000 autos sind da meine persönliche
benchmark oder so was aber auf keinen
fall heißt dass es irgendwie weniger
wert ist wenn man die nicht erreicht
oder wenn man die noch nicht hat das
einfach nur so ein ziel weil es macht
einfach leichter wenn man ziele doch
dass man hinarbeiten kann lol ich muss
meiner mutter was talking herr leider
das geht durchaus in eine schulter
ryanair to praise hashtag essentiell
was ist dein lieblings reise ort an dem
noch nicht warst und da muss ich sagen
dass meine hand hoffentlich nicht auf
dem bild ist und ansonsten würde ich
sagen ich würde noch mal gern nach
indien gehen hawaii ich habe auch so ein
kleiner traum von mir ist es mal mit
einem jeep die hawaiianische küste
entlangzufahren das habe ich auch so
eines online ist kannst du er tödlich im
vest nachvollziehen er seit der nämlich
kosten der jeep und das war einfach geil
stellt euch mal vor seinen job
vielleicht ein pickup auf dessen
ladefläche noch schlafen können und war
damit so die küste lang das wäre ich
schon richtig geil auf hawaii weil er
keiner weiß halt einfach geil schön
entspannt ich glaube die leute andere
mentalität als ihr wisst ihr was ich
wechsele mal kurz die hand
so muss mich jetzt hier nicht
over the top unnötig quälen so ist viel
besser alter reisen thema wurde schon
mal gefragt maltes zahl müsse es einfach
mal gefragt hashtag essentiell wirst du
bald wieder öfter stream ps seines teams
sind super ob sie jetzt habe ich noch
ungefähr werde ich machen
ich habe mir den zweiten bildschirm
bestellt übrigens es werden wieder
öfters teams kommen aber momentan habe
ich einfach nicht sind die zeit dafür
was auch mit der grund dafür ist dass es
diesen video auch gerade gibt das ich
gerne wieder aufmachen und kein gaming
weil ich einfach so zwischendrin ist
ganz gut diesen wiederum machen kann ich
bin sauer auf dem heimweg nach hause
setz mich dann hin karte den habe wie
gesagt hat wenig zeit bin im letzten
teil die ganze ganzen tag in der uni als
nicht so dass wir deswegen schlecht
gewählt oder so aber es verwaltet
bisschen mehr zu tun und deswegen auch
keine zeit zu streamen abends motive
zurückzukommen
ja aber demnächst passiert dass tony
scott regina hat noch eine frage und
fragt herr staeck essentiell
ich denke du hast das von adi gestern
mitbekommen was sagst du dazu ich habe
tatsächlich was die twitter gesehen aber
es halt wieder wie üblich ist wieder ein
bisschen bisschen übellaunig und
beschwert sich über leute die ihre
reichweite missbrauchen was eigentlich
legitim ist aber wie seit ich finde er
macht sich das selbst so viel trubel
herrschen
publicis sehr gute frage von arthur auch
noch hashtag essentiell kannst du
irgendwann mal mit einem mitbewohner ein
gta 5 live stream machen da er zu
eine sehr gute frage gestellt denn ich
habe heute den beschluss gefasst den
entschluss gefasst nicht beschluss dass
ich am 14
gta 5 von den pc heraus kommt mir das
ziehen werde über stream über steam und
das let's play und livestream werde
unter der voraussetzung dass ihre auf
bock drauf habt und zwar habe ich dafür
schon kollegen an buch angeworben neben
dem straßenkurs der meinte ja gta 5
kommt raus voll geil und wir waren beide
voll gehabt habe richtig bock drauf
gianluca heißt er und mit dem welches
ein eventuelles play live stream der hat
ein gutes headset hatten
ps mein t shirt angehen da kann man das
machen ja da hab ich auch übrigens
richtig richtig richtig hart bock drauf
hoffen
seltener auf dem spiel so viel bock habt
ihr auf gta 5 muss ich sagen
farina in japan effekt heftig
essentielle 19 tagen sind video days
steht genaueres zu deiner anwesenheit
fest nein bis jetzt nicht es sollte ich
komme dann ist es vielleicht ne super
spontane aktion was ist superfit spontan
ich kann meine jacke ausziehen moment
warum laufe ich mit winterjacke rom
sogar das ist nicht so
die kameras karim ausgang jetzt ist sie
wieder an und ja sie ist ein
ich hatte gerade immer für so eine coole
aufgabe wie ich dann diesen wald gerannt
bin vollkommen bescheuert ich von vorn
los zu rennen dann merke ich auch steht
die kameras aus und jetzt wieder
heftiger youtuber ich hab mir jetzt
überlegt lange ich das noch mal rein
einfach nur für die aufnahme natürlich
nicht ist er für das wäre falsch
bollstedt und am arsch deswegen auch mit
den fragen würde ich mal sein
romy hat gottschalk romy fragt lemmy
händler der hast du schon mal etwas
verbotenes gemacht ja selbstverständlich
und ich finde auch man sollte auch
ehrlich gesagt verbotene dinge in seinem
leben tun wobei verboten ja vieles sein
kann
also wenn man sich damit selbst schadet
ist es vielleicht nicht so vernünftig
also verboten im sinne von wird was sich
eine bank ausrauben oder so bei gc heißt
natürlich sehr gerne aber im echten
leben vielleicht nicht so vernünftig ob
man sich damit selbst viel verbaut wenn
es jetzt aber darum geht ja irgendwie
nachts ins schwimmbad können auch ein zu
brechen oder sowas dann richtig das habe
ich wirklich nicht gemacht aber andere
verbotene dinge würde ich schon sagen ja
das ist relativ gut dass es gut ist
einfach ja das gehört schon dazu wenn
man immer nur erlaubte den gemacht das
ist auch langweilig dann schreckt man
sich selbst zu sehr ein finde ich
persönlich stichwort video days ich weiß
gar nicht ich muss man auf die frage
eingehen von japan ich weiß nicht wie
weit ist jetzt gerade drauf auf der
aufnahme von gerade eben ja eventuell
spontan hoch wie gesagt nach berlin
am ersten zweiten meisten der glaubliche
video days muss ich mal schauen als ist
dass facebook wie weg hier gilt es dass
man richtig selbst inc wir fahren hier
auf jeden fall die harten offroad rennen
mit ihren traktoren umgepflügt dieser
weg ist ja ok aber eventuell feucht das
spontan hoch muss ich mal schauen
ich habe eigentlich hat bock darauf euch
da mal so zu treffen wir haben uns lange
lange lange eigentlich nur so über das
internet gesehen
und ja ich immer die fans im echten
leben zu sehen dass wir wieder geil so
was mache ich eigentlich auch gerne sehr
gerne und das ist eigentlich mag ich
sehr gerne
das können wir in berlin macht aber ich
weiß noch nicht ob mein stundenplan mir
vonseiten der uni aus das erlaubt
vielleicht kann ich aber auch einfach
vielleicht stellt sich aber einfach noch
ein paar veranstaltung und gehe dann
trotzdem in längste so so zum abschluss
noch eine frage hier von lexisnexis
lifestyle wo siehst du dich in fünf
jahren ist eine frage die gar nicht so
leicht zu beantworten ist deswegen
welches ein bisschen abstrakt halten ich
hoffe einfach in fünf jahren mache ich
irgendwas an dem ich spaß habe wovon ich
auch selbst leben kann
idealerweise irgendwas selbstständiges
vielleicht weiterhin youtube oder so
oder ich habe da schon irgendwie
unternehmen begründen
mich rasiere nicht man muss ich kurz
kern ja idealerweise was auch
selbstständig ist weil es mir einfach am
meisten spaß macht wenn ich zur
selbstverantwortung habe vielleicht dann
noch in einem zweiten studium war ich ja
auch theoretisch vorhabe da noch was zu
studieren da noch drin in fünf jahren
also irgendwas cooles macht irgendwas
cooles mache neue dinge lernen neue
leute kennenlernen mehr braucht man
eigentlich gar nicht im leben so und
etwas zu essen vielleicht noch aber doch
vielleicht so wollte das war es auch
heutige blog seid doch so gut und lassen
noch mal einen burger damit wir das auch
schaffen
am 18 april nach münchen gehen kann und
der lukas und justin treffen kann
hier muss gerade beim bauernhof hier
drüben seht ihr es noch eine flasche
apfelsaft muss man kein most aber
frischen apfelsaft und so ein kilo äpfel
geholt habe ich bock drauf gehabt mega
gut und das heute von mir das genommen